theoretical question which is considered
to be the
most central problem in theoretical
computer science or
at least computational complexity theory
combinatorial algorithm theory
the question is whether p is equal to np
if p were equal to np it would be
amazing it would mean
that every
problem where a solution can be rapidly
checked
can actually be solved in polynomial
time we don't really believe that's true
if you're scheduling classes at a school
it's we expect that if somebody hands
you
a satisfying schedule you can verify
that it works
that doesn't mean that you should be
able to find such a schedule
so intuitively np encompasses a lot more
problems than p
so can we take a small
tangent and break apart that intuition
so do you first of all think that
the biggest sort of open problem in
computer science maybe mathematics
is whether p equals np do you think
p equals np or do you think p
is not equal to np if you had to bet all
your money on it
i would bet that p is unequal to np
uh simply because there are problems
that have been around for centuries and
have been studied intensively in
mathematics
and even more so in the last 50 years
since the
p versus np was stated and
no polynomial time algorithms have been
found for these
easy to check problems so one
one example is a problem that goes back
to the mathematician
gauss who is interested in
factoring large numbers so
we know what a number is prime if it
doesn't
if it cannot be written as the product
of two or more
numbers unequal to one
so if we can factor the uh a number like
91 that's 7 times 13
but if i give you
20 digit or 30 digit numbers you're
probably going to be at a loss to
have any idea whether they can be
factored
so the pr the problem of factoring very
large numbers
is does not appear to have an efficient
solution
but once you have found the factors
express the number as a product the two
smaller numbers you can quickly verify
that they are factors of the number
and your intuition is a lot of people
finding you know this
a lot of brilliant people have tried to
find algorithms for this one particular
problem there's
many others like it that are really well
studied and it would be great
to find an efficient algorithm for right
and in fact we have
some results that i was instrumental in
obtaining
following up on work by the
mathematician stephen cook
to show that within the class
np of easy to check problems
there's a huge number that are
equivalent in the sense that either
all of them or none of them lie in p
and this happens only if p is equal to
np
so if p is unequal to np we would also
know
that
virtually all the standard combinatorial
problems
if p is unequal to np none of them can
be solved in polynomial time
you